governments can protect themselves just
fine as can big corporations you can
bunker eyes your operations to an
arbitrary degree so that you're using
best practices and if there's a denial
of service attack against you you can
deploy the resources to absorb it or two
deflect it if you think about it Google
suffers continuous distributed denial of
service attacks they're so damn popular
how many Google searches are happening a
second right I don't care how many
zombies you're going to send to attack
Google it's like there's so many people
already zombie if I'd going to Google
because they're desperate for a search
that it's just a drop in the ocean the
real problem is if smaller to medium
sized businesses find themselves clogged
or personal connections or clogged and
then you can't get to the government
sites that are so well defended but you
can't reach them because of the traffic
that you're competing against on your
end of things and for that I do think we
need to start taking the zombie and
malware problems pretty seriously I
sometimes ask very good hackers who
don't agree that there's a big problem I
say look if you were in a 24 like
situation where the bad guy has a gun to
your head and you're not as brave as key
34 Sutherland and he says you have a
week to bring down a quarter of the
machines on the net could you do it
generally their answer is yeah ed
Felton's answer was kind of two weeks
he's a computer scientist at Princeton I
think they're thought though is that if
they had to they could wreak great havoc
and why hasn't it happened yet in part
because the people capable of doing it
have business models that depend on on
havoc getting wreaked but on leaching
taking a little of your band with a
little of your processing cycles and
sending some spam with your machine but
not having you notice being more of a
chronic illness and something that's
going to kill you outright somebody
wanted to do cyber warfare and kill it
outright they wouldn't have those limits
you